[Music]
so does it mean i have to download a
cash app cause i don't have a cash app
so
no i'm gonna take his money and then
i'll give him some cash
he's gonna give it to me cash i'm gonna
take my money give it to your cash
[ __ ] love it that's a lot of money yeah
that would suck it's so weird i think
they sold out but there's
there's still a lot of empty seats yeah
it does when they
do the aerial view there's a bunch of
red empty seats just so [ __ ] hot
people stayed home
there was no touch of the gloves no
touch of the gloves
love it steven a smith hasn't chimed in
yet huh
oh man save us all
show trump that machine gun kelly looks
ridiculous there's david's babe
oh [ __ ] man hey what's going on with
these guys in hollywood man
look there's the weird the weird hair
and the weird [ __ ]
[ __ ]
connor has to get it done in under two
under yeah under two two and a half
somewhere around that i don't like that
there it is that's what i want you
kicked the cast
you kick the if car if connor kicks calf
first yeah he does he kicks the cat
first he wins this fight completely
different yeah he's talking [ __ ]
yeah he does look he looks funny he
looks
but here's the thing the spinning stuff
takes a lot of energy on file that i'm a
conor fan
the the the spinning kicks take a lot of
energy that scares me because he does
tend to slow down
not known he's not known for the gas
tank i need the skill pass too
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
there it is i told you faster oh
damn
[ __ ] man 4 000 he's got a kick yeah yeah
you got to lose that
kick right there connors connor's
already felt that kick
one kick from dustin was enough come on
she oh
let's go oh he's switching stance see
that's the difference though dustin
doesn't like to fight in the right hand
stance in the right-hand stance
whereas connor can fight both yeah he's
not as good with the right
hand i would like to pour you to shoot
all right come on i want him to wear him
out he's getting a lot oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] run me my money
oh my god no no oh no
no no
connor's in trouble hurt bro oh [ __ ] man
carter's in trouble
yeah i want the takedowns out of dustin
come on this wears conor out
[ __ ] i hate rooting against connor by
the way
oh he's going for guilty no he's not
he's going take down defense
he just needs to take him down here take
down defense take him down connor's got
good take down eve oh oh
[ __ ] there it is there it is oh he's
gonna pass he's got it no
oh my god he's gonna pass that's tight
but nobody's no
no he's not getting carter's going to
walk his legs up over the fence
they can do he's got to walk his legs
connor's going to walk his legs
there it is oh my god he's got to walk
his legs up over the fence
oh no he's locked his hands
dude and i love connor this is such a
bummer
but i gotta get my money back how much
degenerate i gotta go
god damn it it ain't over yet it's five
rounds it's five rounds
oh he's going for it again no he's got
to get up yes
good on the feet yeah get the back
against the fence get up connor's
breathing a little heavy right now
get out of the counter's face there [ __ ]
man
we never look pretty when you're
fighting that's it no it never happens
you look at the photos after right
you're like why you always guessed with
the ugliest face
there it is those are nice oh good cuts
yeah
those are solid those are how you get
the cuffs get some elbows going in that
little bit of blood starts trickling out
in the face it changes the dynamic of
the fight
oh that's what i'm talking about daddy
goddamn
he's good damn oh oh
come on get up he's got to get up i
don't know why he's playing this bottom
game
just focus on getting back to your leg
papa see he's hanging out in the guard
he's just got to focus on getting his
back to the fence getting back
up he that's what he did against khabib
did a great job against khabib getting
his back to the fence this is so sweaty
i hate this [ __ ]
no oh his ears bleeding like a
he's not gonna let him up no he's just
wearing him out on the bottom here [ __ ]
man
connor's getting some good elbows in too
yeah yeah yeah but
well yeah you never want to get it
dustin's heavy on top man dustin heavy
on top he's a black belt
yeah oh man
oh man big shot big shot by dustin
come on connor's dude oh big up kick is
kicking the [ __ ]
oh he's got some lumps dude he's got
some lumps it's a lot of energy for
connor
oh it's a lot of work though for dustin
though yeah he does he does get better
as the fight goes on
yes he's also someone that adjusts he
saw the
uh hooker fight he adjusted throughout
the fight in the hooker fight
yeah damn it man go ahead that's a long
fight it's a long fight
come on
[ __ ]
will you just walk away with blood
dude connor looks terrible i know yeah
man
he rolled his ankle's broken his legs
broken dude
it's broken look at his flopping around
right now it's like his ankle's broken
he's flopping around
are you serious no it's broken he rolled
it or something is broken
yeah his leg is like that yeah i see
okay yep
that's the anderson silva nasty he has
broken oh my god oh
i'm sorry dude he's [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
classic response bro
now [ __ ] your money whatever
i'm trying to move past that this is
best case scenario for connor because he
was gonna
he's about to get knocked out but but is
he done now like is do
are people going to care about his next
fight as much yeah because he can get
knocked out or finish
because of a leg his life's broken like
that that's the anderson civil times he
was getting his ass beat though yeah
yeah but you know what though in a fight
with his power with his power though you
can't ever count him out
okay that's the biggest thing there was
10 seconds left he said he was getting
beat up he was he was
beat up the fight wasn't over though
that's the thing trying to get in there
he was like yeah he was like you're the
man like get the [ __ ] back
yeah donald trump's right there shut up
here yeah this is hilarious
[ __ ] yeah it's it's so they didn't stop
the fight they just
snap no well there's a ticket no the
round ended yeah i mean you
let's see how bad it is he does
something where he steps back
look it broke it just broke when he
stepped boom
oh [ __ ] oh i hate watching [ __ ] like
that man
damn what did he do what did he like
look he just snapped on it he just
stepped on it
[Applause]
it just snapped yeah man he just
he just rolled the [ __ ] out of his ankle
bro that's a broken leg
yes brooklyn he broke the bone touch the
back
yeah he's lucky the bone ain't coming oh
my god bro
like yeah it's over man but why did it
break why is this [ __ ] so
[ __ ] brittle i just want to know i
don't like that like
what'd you say cutting weight all right
nah
ah that sucks man josh you called it
he's gonna have to go into it you saw
him first have that yeah
nasty that's nasty though yeah that's
the anderson silva
oh look i wish you could hear what
you're saying yeah
subtitles he's saying you son of a [ __ ]
was he trying to blame someone because
his [ __ ] snap like who's he yelling at
[ __ ] i want to hear him but i wish i
could turn the tv
oh no he's not yelling at doesn't bori
interesting there's no captions dude
damn man
well wins a win
damn it i thought i was leaving here
with a thousand bucks i was like damn it
thank you for playing that was a fun
night we overdid it [ __ ] you
his leg his leg fell off
i don't know what you do with this with
connor it's a tough one right
yeah like just just and he's done i i i
i truly believe
he should just leave you run up right i
have 400 million dollars i'm not [ __ ]
right often hey honestly
for a business point of view is probably
the best thing that happens that's what
i'm saying because yeah
you get knocked out again like from a
business angle it's a nightmare yeah
yep do you think he fights after this
you're gonna get the diaz trilogy fight
in like a year or two but other than
that no this is it
best case scenario for counter because
if he were to get finished or knocked
the [ __ ] out it'd been
terrible yeah wow man